رغم الانتشار الواسع لفكره الاسره الصغيره
في الدول المتقدمه لكن ايضا الاسره
الكبيره التي تعرف بانها العائله التي
لديها اربعه اطفال او اكثر لا تزالوا سمه
ظاهره في العديد من البلدان الغنيه حيث
ينشا ما يقرب الخمس الاطفال الذين
تتراوحوا اعمارهم بين الاحاد عشر و13 عاما
في الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا في اسر
المكونه من اربعه اطفال او اكثر
دراسه اجرتها جماعه واشنطن اثرت الى تراجع
معادلات الاطفال الذين تنجيبهم المراه في
واحد وتسعين دوله حول العالم وفق الدراسه
فقد سجلت معدلات الخصوبه في النيجر الرقم
القياسيه اذ بلغ متوسط انجاب المراه سبعه
اطفال مقابل طفل واحد وتجيبه المراه
القبرصيه وتراجع معدل الانجاب في سنغافوره
واسبانيا والبرتغال والنرويج وكوريا
الجنوبيه الى اقل من طفلين وهي الدول
المتقدمه وترجع دراسه هذا الانخفاض الى
تاخير فكره الانجاب او التخلي التامه من
عنها سين وراء توفير المزيد من فرص
التعليم والعمل للطفل مع تحسن الظروف